the whole experience of going to the
show is a little surreal beforehand they
prep you with all right if you win
you've got 50 seconds from the time they
call your name until you know that's it
the orchestra starts playing so don't
waste any time getting up there and the
Oscar goes
to John No Hal hickle Charles Gibson and
Alan Hull for the Pirates of
cariban when we did hear our names try
to get up on the stage as quickly as
possible and you know you want to make
good use of that time one thing that
that I was not prepped for is you get on
the stage and there's all these lights
in your eyes and you can hardly see
anything one thing you can see very
clearly right in the center of your
vision is there's a big screen TV with
giant numbers counting down cuz you know
you're trying to remember to
appropriately make use of that time
thank the people that they're so
responsible to you're being up there and
then all of a sudden you see 17 16
and first got got to thank uh jar Brock
Heimer for entrusting us with this great
big project for me probably the most
emotional part of it was that next
Monday after the show when we came back
here the whole company had had gathered
and the joy and the emotion on
everyone's faces was actually really
emotional thing to see just how happy
everybody was because they were all a
big part of making that happen and so
that was that was the best part of it
for
me
I